[Music]
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real peace
whatever it is that you and your friends
do it somewhere else you have nine
seconds to decide your face you don't
want trouble
you're starting to warming call
all the mafia will come to destroy you
hurry up
The Equalizer three without multiple
bodies do you kill him do I look like a
killer
through September 1st you like being in
other people's business trying to wear a
hard not to be you make it very
challenging for me are you warning me
that's the median nerve that I'm
compressing on a scale one to ten that's
a two I said three
you don't want me to go to four
all the mafia will come to destroy you
I'll be waiting for you The Equalizer
three in theater September 1st I like
this place and I'm starting to believe
this is where I'm supposed to be
nine seconds that's what I'm giving you
to decide your faith
we've started a warm a call I'll be
waiting for it hurry up five four that's
a level three you don't want it to go to
a level four three two
equalizer three alien theater September
1st
[Music]